hi there and thanks for joining in this
sample I will demonstrate how to enable
cross origin resource sharing otherwise
known as cores for your apog API proxy
let's get started cores is an HTTP
mechanism enforced by modern browsers to
allow or deny the sharing of data
between different origins in this slide
we see that the Chrome browser is
accessing from the origin domain a.com
in the top right we see the browser
called to The Domain a.com web server
since both the browser and the web
server are on domain a.com it is a same
site request and is not impacted by
cores in this slide we also see a
request from the browser to domain b.com
since the browser and the server Origins
do not match this is a cross origin
request these requests will be either
allowed or denied by the server's cores
policy or lack thereof at a high level
this is what a basic cores error will
look like for a simple request if Coors
is not enabled on the server the request
will be sent and processed by the server
but the response will be blocked by the
browser on its way back to the web
app but these requests between Origins
can be enabled with a simple apog cores
policy if desired with cores there is
also the important concept of pre-flight
requests non-simple requests such as put
requests or requests with custom
non-standard headers trigger pre-flight
requests that confirm the course
configuration before sending the
original request the pre-light request
will always be an options request and if
it fails then the original request will
not send it all in this sample I will
show you how to configure cores for your
apogee apis so your apis can
successfully serve cross origin requests
let's get started now before we begin
this accelerator sample be sure to read
the intro sections and not the
prerequisites you'll be able to follow
along with the instructions either in
Cloud shell or right here in this
repository in this video we will follow
along with Cloud shell so without
further Ado click the cloud shell button
this will download the entire apogee
samples GitHub repository code into your
cloudshell
editor first CD into the correct folder
if needed you can ensure that you are
signed into the correct account with
this
command next update the environment file
with your own apog
information
then Source your environment
file now run this command to deploy the
API proxy directly into your environment
once that finishes we'll navigate to the
next page and follow the instructions
there the instructions say to navigate
to the apy homepage so let's do that
then go to develop and then API proxies
before clicking into the sample course
proxy
once inside navigate to the develop tab
next let's take a look at our proxy it
only has one policy a course policy
named course- add course please review
the course policy documentation as it
can do much more than shown in this
video and CH is a very important topic
to fully understand let's navigate to
the debug tab from the debug tab choose
to start a debug session with the
debugger still running navigate to an H
GTP request service such as test-c
course.org these requests will need to
be sent from an online browser service
first let's see what it looks like when
a request fails due to cores from
test.org find the remote URL field and
enter in your no cores proxy endpoints
URL leave all other fields at their
default values click the send request
button and view the response your
request will fail as it does not trigger
the course- addc policy within AP
to see the core's error message open up
your browser console in Chrome this is
done by right clicking the web page
selecting inspect and then choosing the
console tab you should see a Coors error
message inside let's navigate to the
apog debugger despite the cor's error
you should still see a 200 status code
for that request while 200 status codes
usually indicate success we know that in
this case the request was blocked by the
browser due to course now let's navigate
back to test.org and trigger a
successful cross origin request in the
remote URL field update the URL with a/
enable proxy suffix instead of SL Noor
leave all other fields at their default
values and click the send request button
again you should see a 200 status code
this time meaning that the response
returned back to the client
successfully now let's navigate back to
the apy debugger you will still see a
200 status code for that request but
this time we know that the request
wasn't blocked by the browser this is
because we met the necessary conditions
to execute the cores dad cor policy now
let's trigger a request with a course
pre-flight course pre-flight requests
are sent ahead of your request if your
request is not simple so far all of our
requests have been simple so let's
change that for our next test by adding
Fu bar into the request headers field in
test.org our cores d ad course proxy
policy has already been configured to
allow the new header Foo click the send
request button and view the response you
should see a 200 status code meaning
that the response has returned back to
the client successfully let's navigate
to the apy debugger you will still see a
200 status code for your get request but
you should also see an options request
as well that options request was our
pre-flight request sent by Kors to
ensure that our API is properly
configured before sending the get
request now let's go back to Cloud shell
scroll down and click into the next
section optionally you can rate this
accelerator and can clean up the CH
proxy that we created in this video and
delete it to do so run the cleanup
script within
cloudshell thanks for watching I hope
this video is useful to you if you have
not yet signed up for apogee use the top
link and if you have any questions
please please visit the apy community
thank you